I told myself when I was super poor and
I had yo dude I had two pairs of shoes M
I had a black pair of shoes that I wore
to cater and I had a pair of sneakers
that were my workout shoes that you wore
everywhere else that I just wore right
okay and we were on Home
Improvement
and this was I remember putting the new
shoes on because they gave me new shoes
mhm and I was like oh you forgot what
new shoes it felt like and the woman was
like what what
uh you don't like him I was like no I
just and I was kind of touching him I
was like I just haven't had new shoes in
a bit she goes how long has it been I
said probably four or five years damn
and she was like what and I go yeah I
just don't haven't had the money and
spending money on the kids and you
know and um dude
I was there for a day M and when I
changed and I said goodbye and I
was the they had so cool it's gonna make
me a tiny little bit emotional okay but
clip
it
that um wardrobe
lady wrapped up those [__] shoes dude
put a bow on them man that's awesome it
was it
meant it meant so much
dude it meant so much I had so little
and it I it was just super cool just to
be on a set for a day and not worry
about you guys or not worry about how I
was
gonna put food on the table
or it was the day you got to focus on
yourself I just got to forget yeah and
then as I was starting to remember oh I
got to go
back to be able to put those
[__] new shoes on that's awesome was
something I will never forget that
feeling for the rest of my life do you
remember her name I don't remember her
name I
remember
um I I kept those shoes in a box dude I
would wear them and I awesome I would
clean them and I would put them and they
dude they were like Asic yeah but still
it it was not it was just a new shoe
and the fact that this woman looked out
for you yeah when she did not have to at
all eighty at all minimal effort maximum
result [__] that's it was such a cool
thing I I will never forget it for the
rest of my life I'll never
forget the feeling of such a small for
her such a tiny gesture but it meant
like so it was such a big thing for me
honestly you talk talking about that
kind of for for people like for me a guy
somebody who who knows you because
you're my dad it gives me a little more
also Insight like you are the way you
are because you were raised right you're
a good person you have a moral compass
like all of the above things right but
that
experience gives me a feels like it
gives me a little insight into your
brain as to why you do some of the
things that you do and I feel like that
experience with that wardrobe Ru
wardrobe woman sorry set set something
permanent in your head to always be even
if you didn't have anything to always be
looking out for someone who had less
than you I definitely do that that time
in my life is what definitely showed me
that
[Music]
I I can say for
me and I think it's and I don't think I
know it's one of the reasons that I try
to be that way with other people I can
say for me that I would not have gotten
through those times without the kindness
of strangers yeah without out people at
the park looking out for
me and
uh looking like it was amazing there was
a
community and uh I I am I do try to do
that for other people because yo when
people didn't have to help me and people
who didn't know
me um they did man and it it meant a lot
and it means a lot when you can do that
for other people and so I definitely try
it's one of the reasons I I try to be
kind to everybody yeah absolutely and
and give what I can you also just never
know what somebody else was going
through kind of 100% 100% you would have
had no idea what I was going through in
my life and these people still looked
out for me it was it
was it was something I'll never forget
dude it was it was um it really did
shape me including you know obviously
our family and right right right but
there were people around the
neighborhood vendors that woman at
Ralph's who made sure she gave me free
free food every day yeah yeah yeah um
she really that woman she could have
gotten fire yeah and that was not a
woman who could but I could tell she
knew yeah what I was going she
sympathized or empathized something she
I could tell she looked at me and was
like I've been there right and so it was
like
um it was uh it's why I'm so very
grateful
about where I am right now look dude I'm
not we're not big balling I'm not yeah
dude I'm not I'm not bur rer I'm not
selling 30,000 tickets at Bridgestone
I'm not
sagora I'm not Andrew Schultz or I'm not
even Trevor Wallace or any of these
dudes and it doesn't matter I'm so very
grateful
to be where I am because I
know where I've been right and so like
and there wasn't any
overnight success wasn't it's not like
oh I can just kind of Glide now that's
not it
either but I I I think you know this I
think this past year has been filled
with so much joy for me including with
my work yeah dude I I this is for sure
been a new you like obviously you've
always had energy on stage you've always
been super fun to watch perform and
obviously I'd seen your sets for years
but every time I hear jokes I'm still
laughing at the same punch lines like
you're you really do look like you have
a new like pep in yourr Step energy on
stage from this year I'll take the
credit for it um a lot of it a lot of it
is you man there's no doubt a lot of it
is you but you're also like I can see
your brain firing more too like like
you're like just like my creative brain
is opening up your cre your brain's
always been creative but I still again
see new switches flipping on for you and
it's really cool to see you just
enjoying your time and I remember at a
time when you were touring you like I
would do anything to get off the road
and look we would love to stay in town
and find something that would keep us
here but traveling has become a little
less tedious for sure well I I don't
tedious but it's still exhausting but
it's a little less because you know
we're doing it together I don't think
there's any doubt dude that you have
added years to my desire to be on the
road not only am I you know thought you
just gonna say be funny but that works
too dude you know what I didn't realize
is how lonely I
was dude the last time you did a UK
Europe tour you did it by yourself
Australia too that that sounds like
obviously it's like cool self-
exloration and you probably did a lot of
soul searching especially on that one
but like I I would be I would go nuts
yeah you did it for so long I I didn't
quite realize how lonely I was I was
just like you know sometimes when you're
when you get in a habit or you know
things are
habitual uh like oh this is just how
life is and so I was like oh just Comics
are supposed to be alone and but but um
I think you really noticed though though
on the weekends that Mom or me came on
the road you were like oh this is so
much better so much better and I'm I'm
also you know we had a little heart-to-
heart last night in the car we've had
one for pretty much that meant so much
to me last night and I'll I'll tell
everybody um this year for me really has
been such a a crazy it's never where I
thought I'd be in life like at the end
of last year working as a PA still when
I finally decided I wanted to change my
career and change my path in life
because I was the only one who could
change it what happened this
year I couldn't have even imagined what
we did this year where we went the
crowds We performed in front of it it
exceeded any sort of expectation I could
have ever had especially also with me
and like finding a new career path and
now I'm not just there to to sell merch
and do a Q&A I'm I'm opening for you
this has officially become what we had
kind of always talked about and the
expectations for this year were super
high but they were so above what I could
have even imagined and I can't wait to
see what we do next year because it's
going to be it's going to be wild but
also on on on all of that and the only
way I had this opportunity is because of
you so thank you for for all this it's
been legit I know we joke a lot on stage
about how I'm like yeah you know coming
on the road is cool and seeing him is
all right I guess but it really has been
like you know I'm seeing mom more too we
all live in the same state it really has
been a year of it's been a game changer
so I thank you and I love you and thank
you so much for the any opportunity
you've ever given me what I what I've
done just period in almost 27
years you've done some pretty good [__]
I've done some ridiculous [__] and it
really is because of the work you put in
and the opportunity you or and the
position you put yourself in to work
hard for you and your family and most of
the things we've done are because of you
so dude just so you know my absolute
pleas also keep working hard so we can
do cool
[Laughter]
[__] oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
man